in 2022 you either die a hero or live
long enough to sell nfts that's the new
youtuber life cycle and today we get the
rare chance to see the final form of the
greedy influencer that's right the
legendary doubleless downus i'm of
course talking about jake tran's recent
response jake tran is a youtuber who
spent years exposing evil businesses but
now has been doing the same things that
he accuses others of and last week i
showed how he had started selling nfts
in videos about how bad nfts are we're
selling crypto in a video about how
crypto is and it was just so weird to
watch it felt like your high school
counselor was suddenly trying to sell
you drugs right after a dare
presentation i mean on the one hand it's
so shameless it's funny on the other
hand it's very gross now soon after this
video came out jake got backlash from
his community and he finally responded
to all the accusations and honestly i'm
surprised i was expecting a response
somewhere along the lines of either i
didn't know it was a scam or it's not a
scam but he didn't even try that what
did you expect out of a channel that
teaches you to be evil lol now i'll be
honest i clearly was fooled i thought
his whole series on evil business videos
were exposed but apparently it's a big
to-do list like i think jake saw this
all as a big wikihow he's the type of
guy to think that the wolf on wall
street is like a checklist and not a
cautionary tale you know on the one hand
i do really appreciate the honesty of
this but on the other much more
important hand uh you're kind of
admitting that you don't care if your
audience gets scammed by you which
it seems really wrong now that being
said i'd at least respect it if he fully
committed to the villain arc but jake
softens it in the next paragraph and
says in all seriousness i put my heart
and soul into making free premium videos
every sponsor on this channel helps fund
this channel so we can keep upping the
quality and quantity so if you don't
like the sponsors skip the ads don't buy
from them or unsubscribe from the
channel
so basically
he's not sorry he had to do the scam ads
to keep up with the quantity and quality
of his videos
but i don't know if i really buy this to
be honest i mean look i like jake tran
videos but let's not pretend they cost a
fortune to make he literally uses b-roll
from other people's movies for his
visuals and then he farms out his
research to like articles and wikipedia
maybe a book or two so this whole thing
about like i had to do these ads
otherwise i couldn't possibly produce
this
quantity and quality of videos it's like
my guy you barely make your videos as it
is your visuals are from filmmakers
you're snagging their clips for fair use
and then lately he's been farming out
even the voice over of his work which
it's like i'm not against that but
pretending you're making some
oscar-winning documentaries that require
our blood money to fund is a little bit
much and then there's also the thing
about like hey just don't click it if
you don't like it just unsubscribe but i
don't think jake realizes that this
undermines every single one of his
videos because why would you complain
about tobacco or dupont or any of these
evil businesses when they could just
turn around and say the same thing like
hey if you don't like it don't buy it
unsubscribe why are you buying our
cancer sticks right like which would
obviously be missing the point but is
the exact same argument and this isn't
even to mention the fact that jake tran
isn't a soulless corporation at least
not yet but rather is a youtuber with
some level of accountability to his
audience and that all makes the next
part of his response even more confusing
he says i love all of you more than any
of you could realize you changed my life
in every way possible
uh okay
i don't know what to do with this like
nothing in these two paragraphs seems to
have anything to do with the other
they're diametrically opposed like
unsubscribe if you don't like the scam
ads i'm running but also
i love you very much i don't know if i
buy this i mean i'm sure his life did
change but um i think he's happier about
the money part of the equation clearly
jake finally ends the response i
apologize for nothing uh stay dangerous
so he's not sorry uh all of you who got
ripped off just in case you are
wondering if you felt any bit of remorse
the answer is no and i'm assuming he's
one of these guys who thinks apologizing
on the internet is like having your
pants pulled down in front of the whole
class it's the worst thing that could
happen to you and maybe that's true for
some influencers but if you're the guy
exposing corruption you can't just like
shrug off being corrupt yourself it
destroys your whole appeal
and i think this just highlights a
problem that i have with jake's general
mentality like i may be wrong about this
but i think he thinks that being a
little bit evil is like necessary and
important to survive in this world in
fact that's sort of the point of his
entire stay dangerous sign off he said
before that this is the purpose of his
channel and even quotes machiavelli to
suggest that you can't be a good guy and
that has become the purpose of this
channel to expose how this world of
power really works to help you navigate
this world to level out the playing
field for the powerless to help you
become more dangerous because as
machiavelli once said any man who tries
to be good all the time is bound to come
to ruin among the great number who are
not good so there it is he just says it
like his job is to make you more
dangerous i guess by selling you scammy
nfds um but it's pretty clearly and
heavily implied that like being good and
doing things the right way is like a
suckers game uh it's a loser's bet which
obviously i really disagree with i think
jake thinks he's found the red pill of
life and i just kind of feel bad for him
for that because i'm almost positive
this is going to backfire on him in a
big way but i don't know maybe that's my
naive perspective i have seen a lot of
influencers just getting away with
scamming their audience and they just
don't care so maybe we're in a new world
but uh in my opinion you know you can
get ahead in the short term by cheating
a little selling out your audience but
once you get that reputation it sticks
and all in all i think it was a pretty
terrible response uh maybe like a three
out of ten that's basically it see ya